was him obeyed is tending the grave of
his aunt she died in 2017 at home in
Gaza having spent the previous 26 years
hoping and working for the return of her
son Farris marude was captured by
Israeli forces in 1991 he'd killed an
Israeli settler he died in prison in
February his body is still in Israeli
morgue
his mother is dead he has no immediate
family in Gaza but we're not letting it
go we're waiting we know it's not easy
to get his body back every year
activists and family members staged a
day of protest in Gaza and in the
occupied West Bank to remember their
loved ones and to renew their demand
that they be returned they gave no
comment to our inquiries but the
families and the activists say the
motivations for keeping the bodies are
clear one collective punishment against
the relatives to distort political
leverage negotiations it's a tactic also
used by Hamas in Gaza it's holding on to
the remains of two Israeli soldiers
killed in the 2014 war Palestinian
campaigners say Israel is withholding
more than 300 bodies most in numbered
graves most dating from the violence of
the Second Intifada in the early 2000s
that's when Jaleel AB shot son Amin was
killed a fighter in Hamas is al-qassam
brigades he was attending what he
thought was a secret meeting with other
factions at a school near the city of
Jeannine he was one of five killed when
Israeli forces attacked I wish I could
just lay my eyes on him one last time I
want them to hand his body over so we
can bury him according to Islamic law
but the prospects are slim especially in
the absence of talks between the
Palestinian leadership and the Israelis
more likely that she and the other
families will be repeating their demands
in another years time Harry Fawcett
al-jazeera
in the occupied West Bank